[Music]
[Applause]
good morning and welcome back to the
break room this is our daily live show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know and today the
nerdy news is coming pretty early in the
morning sometimes 9 55 shots
we've been on uh on call all month
waiting for the DCU uh slate to drop and
it has happened we're going to be
talking dcu's first chapter today that's
what they're calling it uh very exciting
stuff how long is the first chapter
supposed to be is it a span of 10 years
I think this is all what we're going to
talk about today is in the next two to
three years is what's going to happen
and joining me today we got Jessica
clemming I'm so pumped I'm gonna go
crazy on this what Wonder Woman's back
Jessica's really excited we also have
Tommy bechtold of course connective
storytelling voice actors playing the
same roles
on here that's not my DC restore the DC
EU
well uh we don't have a Redemption for
today but if you guys have questions uh
throw them in the chat if you got super
chat you want to send in we'll read them
out you want us to you want us to read
your weird esoteric request about a
superhero that no one's ever heard of
that was in four issues in 1980 you're
gonna have to pay for it that's right
that's right we know you guys out there
you love Marvel and Star Wars but you DC
heads you've been waiting for your
moment now's your time to shine rise
rise my DC pretties fly all right that
is exactly how James Gunn felt when he
was giving the announcement he was like
feeding these little these little
animals that's right that's right he was
so excited to put on his best T-shirt
this morning and do a little video for
us dye that hair more white so James
guys it has to no that's natural baby
that's beautiful that's beautiful white
hair James Gunn's DCU slate is finally
here we've got everything you need to
know in one convenient place okay the
new uh look DCU will be kicking off
theatrically in 2025 with Superman
Legacy uh but more in that in a moment
it's also worth mentioning that gun and
saffron didn't rule out any of the
snyderverse characters making a return
here okay but if you look at like the
upcoming slate uh there's recasts of
Superman there's recast of Batman and it
seems a little less likely that we'll
see any of these characters but we don't
know we don't know he did it he also hit
pretty hard in the video the companion
video that came out obviously all there
was all the articles but then Gunn
himself on his Twitter put out a a five
and a half minute video and he goes when
they he mentioned all of the he's like
he complimented all the four movies that
I've yet to come out still pretty
heavily but he said very specifically in
The Flash Film that that will reset the
DCU timeline not the DC EU timeline the
DCU timeline will be up with flash so I
think it like like you said it opens the
door for like a Jason Momoa as Aquaman
to come in sure but it certainly doesn't
guarantee it right you certainly didn't
leave that feeling like oh we're gonna
see these guys again yeah guys and Gales
it's also interesting because he also I
mean there's at least one show in
particular that I'm like oh so we're
resetting but we're still keeping the
universe like The Peacemaker universe
and yeah we'll get into it but it's like
what is going on right right right uh
they also mentioned that uh this DCU
chapter which is being called Gods and
Monsters okay MC is doing phases the DCU
is doing chapters this is Gods and
Monsters uh there's gonna be different
tones across these different projects uh
for instance Swamp Thing has been
labeled as a horror film while Supergirl
is being called a classic Sci-fi story I
love it I'm so excited you know it I
think one thing sorry I I'm just so
excited to talk about we've all I don't
mean to keep interjecting one thing that
excited me about this you know we
obviously we we cover so much Marvel
because it is so popular and the MCU is
such a great blueprint for franchises
right
this to me the statement they made today
was like we have a total control and
vision and it's not just an MCU carbon
cop right we're doing things like I
think the thing that could Define and
like you know we've had a lot of guests
on the show that have covered DC stuff
and they like you know koi is asking for
DC Black Label feels like they're
folding those tones into one streamline
like one movie can be more comedic and
we will lean into that and refer to it
as a action comedy one movie can be a
straight up science fiction where
they'll go into a lot of like whatever
the physics and chemistry that go into
things or or whatever or science fiction
literally make up science and then yes
Swamp Thing pure horror should be
terrifying people's arms should be
getting ripped off the Mosses should be
eaten good yeah let's take a quick look
at some of that video that Tommy
mentioned from James Gunn that he posted
on his Twitter Hey everybody I'm James
Gunn I'm the co-ceo of DC Studios so as
many of you know DC has been
disconnected and film and television for
a long time and it's one of you know our
jobs mine and Peters is to come in and
make sure the DCU is connected in film
television gaming and animation that the
characters are consistent played by the
same actors and it works within one
story and if something is outside of
that like Matt Reeves Batman or Todd
Phillips Joker or Teen Titans Go that it
is clearly labeled as DC else worlds
outside of the mainstream DCU continuity
I've loved the DC characters since I was
a child they're incredibly important to
me I knew that this was a once in a
lifetime opportunity to do something
very different one of the things that's
very important for me in all of these
movies and TV series is that the
director's vision and the vision of the
writers and all of the creators is
unique and something special
storytelling is always king that's all
that matters to us and I want to be true
to those stories I want to be true to
you guys and really give you something
different than you've ever seen before
anyway thank you everybody I appreciate
you watching I hope this was exciting
for you because it's really exciting for
me and I can't wait to start to dive
into these stories with you guys on this
Grand Adventure thank you so much
what did that t-shirt say we got to get
Eric uh
rebirth reshape reshape rebirth do
something I don't know something do
birth that's what I said to my wife do
birth do birth now she's like I'm not
even pregnant you sicko
we're gonna run down every newly
announced project in order and then
answer some of your questions at the end
we're seeing some super chats coming
through from Smokey the Bear the
salamander get back to class salamander
fly ninja 808 drop out that's what I did
three times throw in throw in your
questions in the chat stay in school and
we'll get to those at the end uh but
Tommy kick us off what's Creature
Commandos
all right it's not gonna do that uh
Creature Commandos an animated seven
episode series entirely written by Jim
Gunn that's James done for foreign this
is already in production I have a
feeling that this has been in some sort
of development since James Gunn came on
to the suicide squad feels like
something he would love this was
originally a team of classic monsters
that were they were assembled to fight
the Nazis you gotta love that and by
classic monsters I'm talking Draculas
Frankensteins Frankenstein's wife's
screechless in the blacks lagoons uh
robot guys like you know I got the team
listed down here in my notes the voice
and so this is where they really leaned
in with the James gonna announce that
the voice actors have not been casting
this but they're looking to cast people
that can play these characters both in
voice performance and in live action
versions uh that's pretty exciting so
here was the original lineup of the
Creature Commandos which I think there
is some crossover we have Lieutenant
Matthew Shreve that was the normal human
now we look all the way over sure some
someone some people's left some people's
right there we've got that hunky Pierce
Brosnan type there although he already
played Dr Fate maybe that could be like
a Joe mangiello maybe we get him back in
that way I think an aging Matthew
McConaughey or you know what Ron funches
I why not who needs give it to Ryan I
don't know everybody
[Laughter]
Warren Griffin a van a werewolf now you
know werewolves are hot we had werewolf
by night in Marvel uh we had Sergeant
Vincent velcro who was a vampire there's
another piece of
um uh creature commando's art that came
out that had a flying bat like person so
I'm wondering if that is the vampire we
had Elliot lucky Taylor a
frankensteinian monster and Dr Mirna
Rhodes a gorgon I don't know is one of
those a gorgon we're gonna have to look
up I remember the fish creatures
or maybe it's a gorgonite from uh from
that uh Small Soldiers uh all right now
it looks like weasel's also joining the
team A Bride of Frankenstein character
looks like I mean obviously updates are
fine you know this was like we don't
need to keep the original Squad but it
is interesting uh that they they do seem
to be sick oh oh I need to mention also
there's that robot Commando uh that that
robot has had many names in the comics
the first name though was GI Joe like
before the the
may have come out concurrently there may
have been a little you know I'm not
saying that these comic book companies
steal or borrow no no no let's just say
they do acted points to confuse
consumers about what they're getting but
uh I thought at first look when we
before I had read any more that that
looked like uh Robot Man from Doom
Patrol oh this does look very similar
like the the gray or the kind of I
believe that it is this GI robot GI Joe
and it would be awesome if his name was
GI Joe on the show I personally very
excited for this it's a cartoon but with
these cartoons now kind of I guess you
know following the model of what if
where it's like a lot of the voice
actors are consistent and the same like
I mean there are obviously some voice
matches that happened in what if but a
lot of those actors came back and did
and did the voices uh of the characters
they play in the MCU I love the idea of
like you do the voice you do it live
action I like that too uh and I looked
it up a gorgon is kind of there's lots
of descriptions from Greek mythology a
Medusa basically as a gorgon oh
similarly well in that case and it's
interesting to see weasel there yeah uh
he's remember weasel survived the
suicide squad he kind of hit the beach
and it seemed like he drowned but then
he woke up at the end he missed the
whole battle and he ran off into the
world do you think they just took him
off the island and he's not eating
children uh I'm sure there's no more
kids left on that island so I'll tell
you one thing that's right I forgot what
a best what Ambassador uh so that's
Creature Commandos Jessica tell us about
Waller this is something Amanda Waller
we know and love uh there was no
Peacemaker too but it they have this
kind of Waller show coming yeah so this
is going to be the spin-off from The
Peacemaker Series so this is what I was
talking about when Tommy was bringing up
how we're kind of restructuring the DC
Universe but we're still keeping
Peacemaker essentially with the spin-off
series that is going to be Waller and we
know Waller because we've seen her in
Suicide Squad we've seen her in
Peacemaker her daughter is a part of the
team and Peacemaker that outs her for
all her bad behavior so we're going off
of that situation this could pick up
where that left off and where Waller
stands and how everyone in the nation
knows who she is now and how she's not a
good person either way I don't think
that's going to stop her from what she's
doing and Waller uh this this series is
going to be created by Crystal Henry of
Watchman and Jeremy Carver of the
creator of Doom Patrol so if it's giving
that kind it's interesting because
Watchman was so dark Watchman was great
dark and dark gloomy amazing and we have
Patrol which still has a lot of
ambitious storylines but isn't as dark
as Watchman it's a little cartoony it's
very fun it plays with characters very
well which I think is much more James
Gunn style so for this series if it's
picking up where Peacemaker sort of left
off whether it's in the middle or the
end we still have Amanda Waller making a
team of people just for the government
on behalf of the government to destroy
hidden secrets in America or the country
well and we were speculating we think we
could see peacemakers show up yeah
absolutely they said he said what a gun
in the video said The Peacemaker team
yeah team members of Team Peacemaker
will show up obviously seems like you
know Steve AG he'll be there when called
upon I mean we have a mother-daughter
possible yeah I wonder how much of
actual Peacemaker will get I'm I'm I
like it does seem like maybe we're not
getting a season two of Peacemaker now
yes
maybe I don't think it's gonna be yet
but I do think I think that's what I
think we will eventually get a season
two okay and I think that's what they're
bouncing off of which they talked about
in a couple articles about this uh it
was the situation of like they're just
trying to make they're blowing out the
world so they can keep going back from
TV shows to movies keep going back how
are we doing Marvel how do we see the
characters come across all the time so
this is one of those characters that
will come across all the time even if
Peacemaker gets It's like got it Dragon
narrow season two again this was just
this is just the next two to three years
as far as we know so and they said and I
believe specifically these are parts of
chapter one yeah these are not this is
not the complete full chapter chapter
one which makes me wonder how many
chapters we get you know this but this
is this this is my third if I have a top
three this is oh okay okay
are we doing Dan Brown chapters where
there's like 89 per book or are we doing
like you know four chapters
long-winded who knows who knows I am
excited for this though because I think
Amanda Waller has been the best
character in a lot of things you know
she shows up she kind of fills in the
gaps yeah I'm excited to focus on her
yeah see what she's got but Tommy you've
got to tell us about DC's number one boy
[Music]
[Applause]
Ah that's right Superman Legacy this is
the new movie uh this is gonna be our
new introduction to the
DCU Superman featuring a Man of Steel
that is being written right now by James
Gunn and I believe I'm sure they're like
come on man this is because they said
he's got to direct something you gotta
direct this movie yeah he's got to drive
although it's when he was talking about
another project coming up usually a
little twinkle in his eye of like I
would actually really like to direct
this we'll sing so uh yeah and he has
not been confirmed in any way to be
directing Superman Legacy right uh so
you know the the the the the the
articles in the video referred to the
two previous titles Waller and uh
Creature Commandos is epitives
appetizers Peter saffron said uh to to
the to the to the first chapter DCU is
the true kickoff
for the DCU plans the the true the true
kickoff of it is this Superman Legacy
yeah Superman Legacy is uh we'll be
we'll be we'll be starting us on our
adventure down chapter one Gods and
Monsters it's not an origin story as we
had thought before it's not it's going
to focus on Superman balancing his
Kryptonian Heritage with his human
upbringing we all saw that absolutely
riveting performance of the baseball
coach that will be dealing with Clark
Kent yes yes yes on the break room I I
have been told that role has been cut oh
I'm sorry unfortunately it was cut
because uh and James Gunn my my cousin's
words uh the role was never written you
made that up you've embarrassed me once
again your invitation to my classic
Easter Crab Boil has been revoked oh uh
and may God have mercy on your soul oh
that's Hollywood baby yeah
Superman he is the embodiment of truth
justice the American way saffron said
his kindness in a world that thinks
kindness is just a bit old-fashioned
sounds like we're making America great
again Superman oh no how dare you I'm
not a Superman on January
he was
I think he was at a meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Sanford and they were
like you're not Superman anymore uh
that's a Henry Cavill not a joke
now this movie has a release date one of
two concrete release dates we got July
11th 2025. oh a week after the Fourth of
July in the year
2025.
mankind is still alive
okay you got it what date yeah I wonder
why it's a week after the Fourth of July
why not just come out because people are
going to barbecues they ain't watching
movies it's a Friday that's why I think
we're all assuming to you know where
will the world be then you know we'll be
celebrating Fourth of July or we'll be
dealing with our Russian Overlord all
right I'm just kidding gun is currently
in the middle of writing this project
and he said in the video he's having a
great time writing it okay well don't
let that delay you keep going buddy stop
making videos for us and get out there
and make Superman that's also we don't
have casting yes yet for Superman we
don't know what other Superman lore
characters will be there we're getting a
Sexy Lexi obviously I assume we're going
to get a Lois Lane give us a good Jimmy
I mean not that the guy who played Jimmy
Olsen in the Snyder movies did bad he
just didn't have anything to do except
for get shot Gangland style execution
style so give us a Jimmy a proper Jimmy
Olsen give us you know bring back uh
Lawrence Fishburn is Perry white if you
want let's make connections let's do it
it uh all right Jessica tell us about
the lanterns okay so I'm finally excited
to see some Green Lanterns
this okay let me read what The Hollywood
Reporter has first and then I'm gonna
get into it because it's very it's so
good our vision for this is very much in
the vein of True Detective saffron
described as terrestrial bass it will
feature prominent Lantern Heroes Hal
Jordan and Jon Stewart and was one of
the most important shows they have in
development this plays a really big role
in leading the main story we are telling
a cross film and TV so the everyone has
been waiting for these two Green
Lanterns and we thought we were going to
probably get them separated but we're
getting them together in the remain of
True Detective so this is going to be
dark this is going to be bad this is
going to be sad no matter what season of
True Detective you watch they're all
pretty dark yeah and so I think pretty
heavy oh take these two Hal Jordan and
Jon Stewart so Hal Jordan was a military
test pilot and he was the member of the
Justice League one of the founding
members and he was abducted by a dying
alien and brought into the uh the Green
Lantern Corps and then we have Jon
Stewart who's also a U.S marine and he
was the replacement to Hal Jordan and
they both did not get along at first
they hated each other they both despised
each other but then they started working
together became allies but put that
world into a lie put that world into the
world of True Detective what does that
look like a a
space True Detective right seems like
they're going to be drinking a lot be
really sad and be fighting because this
is so funny though sorry we you know I I
have to say this is you know sometimes I
can be a bit of a simp like I am
constantly my criticism with the DC EU
and the Snyder verse was like it's so
dark it's so like everybody's so
miserable and hates being the characters
not the actors but the characters are
like oh it just blows to be Batman
that's sucks to be Superman oh it's
washed up to be Wonder Woman oh it
freaks me out to be Flash oh it's yeah
crappy to be cyborg ah whatever etc etc
now so I'm like make it light make it
bright and they're like Superman Legacy
it's gonna be about kindness in a world
that doesn't like that and I'm like that
sounds great then they're like lanterns
It's Gonna Be True Detective a show
historically hard to watch more than one
episode at a time because it's so dark
and I'm like yeah that's exactly what I
want I take back everything I said I do
want that there so they also said these
guys are super cops on Precinct Earth so
like how are you not going to make a
True Detective without being like okay
so we're super cops we have our Green
Lantern rings but we're also on Earth
and we also are like with a bunch of
people that aren't they're normal
civilians right and we're dealing with
the worst crimes we've ever seen on the
planet I think it's awesome I mean I I'm
all in on it I just am like man I
switched on that real fast because I was
like keep it light make it fun and now
I'm like no no dark as can be kidnaps
murderers occult references you hit it
on the head earlier Tommy where it's
like having the different styles all put
at the same time yeah we can have a dark
a couple of Dark shows as long as we
have a little balance on the other it
cannot always be done it can always be
night I think it also maybe we'll get
more Green Lantern core coming through
eventually but I think they're just
going to focus on Hal and John for now
and I mean hey you're getting what you
wanted everyone wanted Hal and John
whether it was together separate and
you're getting both of them I want them
to kiss oh same here I want Phil Lamar
to play uh Jon Stewart like he did in
the Animated Series uh put that man back
on the screen uh that's right and if you
want to watch some of those animated DC
projects you better watch them soon yeah
because they will be leaving right now
is sharpening his ax he's like I know I
said I was gonna put this away and we
were all done with that he's like but
don't believe me just watch
uh the next thing we got to announce was
a project called The Authority this is
gonna be a movie uh this is about a
group of characters from TC they're
actually from a wild storm which is like
a kind of smaller imprint that DC had
they originally created in 1999 uh what
saffron said about them is a quote they
think the world is broken and want to
fix it by any means necessary uh Gunn
apparently wrote the outline for this
movie uh uh uh but he might not not
necessarily be like writing the whole
movie or like directing it again he kind
of had this weird quote where he's like
kind of bouncing all over the place
giving his uh his input on things like
feige does and he kind of wrote an
outline for this thing uh the way they
describe the authority is like they're
not afraid to like do they're good guys
but they're good guys by like any means
necessary right they're not afraid to
like seize control of a government and
dispose of the enemies which maybe a few
governments need that you know what I
mean and the way they existed in the
comics they were kind of separate from
like the main DC Universe but it looks
like they're going to be brought in they
will not be in a separate kind of
universe they're going to exist in
whatever world like the Justice League
exists in in this DCU
um so the members of of uh the authority
uh I'm gonna list come some of them we
don't know which ones they're
necessarily going to have but these are
some of like the original members of The
Authority Jenny Sparks she's a woman who
can manipulate electricity uh she was
caught she's also known as the spirit of
the 20th century because she was born in
1900 and then stopped aging when she
turned 19. oh can't the girl get a drink
she and she's been around and she's like
secretly influenced uh some of the
Century's biggest turning points she
leads the authority okay so she's been
around for a long time she's not afraid
to kill she spent a lot of time in
Canada she's like God damn it who knows
I can't drink there maybe but if I go to
Quebec I can drink when I'm 18. if I go
to Toronto I can drink when I'm 19. or
if I go to Windsor I can drink when I'm
19. Tommy knows the world's drinking
lots or at least Canada's drinking I
know them all everywhere I know where
you can drink anywhere in the world uh
then you also have Apollo who's
described as a solar battery with super
strength uh and vulnerability
invulnerability and flight so a Superman
if you will uh Apollo now was one of the
first openly gay superheroes to appear
in a mainstream comic I mean it was Wild
Storm but still under the DC imprint uh
he's married to midnighter who's another
member of the authority who we'll get to
in a second then you have the engineer
who's a woman infused with Nano machines
she can transfer her body into liquid
metal very T1000 energy there and she
can interface with any machine so she
can just like plug into the hard drive
she can also use her like shape shifting
liquid metal body to create any objects
she imagines uh then you have the doctor
which I kind of laughed about this one
the doctor is the latest in a long line
of Earth Sorcerers just the doctor no
last name very strange to go with that
he's a he's a magic user uh he's also a
recovering junkie trying to put his life
back together yeah I feel that uh he
doesn't have to steal your TV he can
steal your soul with magic it's like Dr
nasty he's a recovering junkies but he
still use it he's not pawning your TV
he's pawning your Immortal Soul uh Swift
swift is a woman with the ability to
manifest wings and Claws and when she's
Airborne she's uh a Speedster one of the
Earth's fastest speedsters and then we
of course we have midnighter uh Apollo's
partner he's a former soldier with
enhanced abilities uh he can see how a
battle will play out before it can begin
so he's like a master tactician and then
we have Jack hawksmore a man who was
given strange abilities after aliens
abducted and experimented on him tough
my guy Jack has super strength and
psychic abilities he's also the group's
resident jerk when you say like he's the
jerk of the authority that's pretty
tough because they're all kind of bad in
a little bit of a way there was like a
Few Good Men reference yeah yeah like
they're they're not afraid to get dirty
and like do the do the the thing that
needs to get done they don't see good
and evil uh as black and white if you
will
um uh uh uh pronit duta said in a Super
Chat saying the authority is going to be
DC's eternals I would say not so much
because I think the eternals are still a
little nice uh maybe he's not Icarus but
they they kind of stand back they try
and influence things but they stay out
of the way the authority they get in the
way they're like we don't like how
things are playing out we're gonna
intervene they see them these are the
guides we're talking about when we talk
about Gods and Monsters yeah and like
they are interfering in and he was uh so
I I could foresee like a Justice League
versus Authority battle setting up later
in the DCU as we get past chapter one or
even deeper into chapter one I don't
know
the project I I want to point out so far
I don't see a thing where where where we
could have Suicide Squad characters
other than weasel like where is Harley
there doesn't seem to be a place yeah
yeah I think Waller can Waller could
happen with them right it's interesting
because it's like they have not talked
about Harley right yeah I'm not talking
about Margaret she's so popular and like
that's the one character that like has
just perfectly she's had she's gotten to
a movie three movies and then on top of
that she has her spin-off uh Harley and
Ivy the Harley Quinn animated but I'm
talking about the cat the Margot Robbie
no but that's why I'm saying word things
are like we we're touching on hardly
enough well there's three things they
might want to leave it for a surprise
right uh Jessica why don't you take us
through this new uh Paradise Lost
project my number one this is my number
one okay this should be both of our
numbers okay because we love all of ours
because we Love Game of Thrones so
Paradise Lost crew but you love Game of
Thrones I do I love it very much so
Paradise Lost
uh the HBO Spirit Max series is a Game
of Thrones style drama set on an
all-female island that is one woman's
birthplace filled with potential
Intrigue and scheming between Power
Players it takes place before the events
of Wonder Woman films so there is a
potential that we could still go back
and watch the Wonder Woman films for any
kind of notes of what their history
might have been but if they do
restructure it this is insane you guys
because they also call this place
Paradise Island so Paradise Lost
Paradise Island it's clearly a bunch of
chaos is going towards you and the
history behind it involves Aphrodite and
Apollo taking the women from Apollo to
this island Aphrodite taking them from
Apollo to this island to be by
themselves and these are the women that
are like no men are allowed on this
planet but there is a and then Aphrodite
gave the um Wonder Woman's mom the
girdle a magic girdle that would always
keep her in power as long as she wore it
but Hercules has stolen it before so
this is already Game of Thrones style
like I need the seat I need the crown I
need the seat I need the crown because
it's like if she loses her girdle she
loses power hour of the island and if
we're going back that far in history
then we're also touching on just the
Greek mythology to it all which is a
power playing move and it's going to be
so bloody
so gory so uh okay like scheming and
it's going to be exactly what Game of
Thrones is but just imagine Wonder Woman
historic you think I mean obviously we
know from Peacemaker this is a TV show
they're not going to be afraid to make
this tvma right they are not going to be
afraid to have people getting swords
through throats and writing dirty notes
well it would be interesting to see if d
uh if Warner Brothers gonna put the
money they put behind Game of Thrones
and House of the Dragon behind a series
like this I would love to see like a
much darker tone yes you know we've had
we saw scenes of the mascaria in both
the first Wonder Woman and Wonder Woman
84. and it was like everyone seemed to
be getting along they would have little
tiffs right like Wonder Woman you can't
leave they had the battle rituals yeah
they had their little tournament but I
would love to see like the dark scheming
of like who gets to be in charge because
if everyone's strong and powerful
everyone feels like they deserve to be
in charge and that's what I'm interested
about this so I think won't appeal too
much for like a younger younger audience
because it's going to be a lot of
dialogue Vlog it's going to be a lot of
mapping of the entire Island and who's
going to own what portion of it and God
forbid Hercules shows up but I put some
of it on Tick Tock for the youngsters
Hercules can do a cute little dance but
I think it is going to be a it's going
to be all the tops it's going to be uh a
piece
yes I think Aphrodite and Apollo might
make their Cameo but it's gonna be like
a lot of Hercules and hippo I can't
pronounce yeah hippolytics it would be
interesting women probably some
amazonians being like this I also
deserve this the season one end with
like the birth of Wonder Woman or like
we she's there the whole time as like a
teenager and we finally meet her in like
the the season finale or something like
that yeah you will do something I'm so
excited for this I also just love any
like High royal fantasy yeah like give
it to me I can't wait to see them stab
each other interesting too uh to note
that very in brand a very on brand very
uh very smart lots of comparison to
existing HBO titles in these they're
like this is True Detective yeah yeah
this is Game of Thrones we're not going
to reference other networks
well I mean they could do a classic like
this is our Star Wars sure but they
don't they're not gonna do like them
editor's name but but if you're going to
I agree but if you're going to compare
it to that you better deliver you better
deliver this is a Game of Thrones like
shows there better be heads on Pikes
episode one you want you want season
four not season eight right
I liked when the horse starts to not
look like a horse and the quality of
Game of Thrones drawing when it just
becomes something else something other
something Brave something oh oh could it
be Batman
Brave and Bold
people are saying that this is going to
be the dcu's plane no I'm just kidding
this will be the introduction of our DCU
Batman we we joked you can't have a new
DCU without a new Batman that's right
and guess what our joke was taken
literally by Jimmy Gunn uh now we
obviously we have Matt Reeves the Batman
which is still happening we'll get into
that in a second we'll go back to Pat
and sin but we don't know casting calls
are going to be out for uh a Batman vote
this is uh the Batman uh comic that I
believe Grant Morrison yes Graham
Morrison run Batman uh is of course
Bruce Wayne Robin Damian Wayne oh okay
he fathers the child with Talia agul so
this is rasagul REI shagul however
whatever version of a DC thing you
watched from 2003 to 2013 however you
want to pronounce it me I call him razor
ghoul uh because I like raising ghouls
now this is Damian Wayne he is a trained
assassin my friend he's a little killer
James Gunners call them a little son of
a [__] this is The Offspring of Bruce
Wayne the entire al Ghul like two Heavy
Hitters uh two good Fighters I mean we
saw Taya go in uh The Dark Knight Rises
right so basically what we have here is
like a mid-30s late 30s Batman raising a
like 12 year old Hellcat who's just
trying to kill people I know we haven't
cast it yet right I'm telling you right
now
a frustrated angry
uh still kind of like arrogant Bruce
Wayne Miles Teller I think would be a
group okay
and then I mean Damien Wayne that
whoever they cast that kid's gonna be
incredible he's gonna be the star the
star of that movie uh so it's a really
weird uh father-son story James Gunn and
uh went on to explain in the in in the
uh in the article it's a murderous Queen
raised by assassins oh okay so a lot
like I said a lot of the early part of
the comic was Batman basically trying to
keep Damien from killing people because
you know Batman is famously occasionally
sort of anti-killing or Pro killing when
it suits him yeah so uh one like Batman
didn't know about this kid right so like
Taya got some some uh formative years in
early and really established an attitude
and a behavior of this kid yes and now
Bruce Wayne comes along he's like uh
he's a little sociopath there's
um I can't remember the exact oh I can't
remember and I just watched it there is
one where Batman's Damian Wayne and
Superman's son are like they're trying
to train them together and David keeps
trying to kill Superman's son because he
can't get his superpowers unless he's in
distress and Damien is literally a rat
he is such a yeah he's he's a like lying
conniving
self-saving like you know selfish
person whose weapon of choice is a sword
like Bruce Wayne's like here's a utility
belt he's like actually no problem I
have a broadsword that I'm gonna use
someone's gonna correct me on what type
of Sword it is in the chat and you
better pay 300 Instagram if you just say
that in the normal chat I will not read
I will block
Tommy will block as a side I was I was
just double checking to make sure I was
also right there is a part in uh the
comics I think when Batman uh Damian
Wayne is actually a child to slayed one
of the like really crazy villains and I
would love this storyline to also just
go in and be like you've been raising
this child your entire life and it's not
actually yours you are not Slade Wilson
or Scott Slade Wilson Slade uh
Deathstroke yes you are not the father
uh now we have a new Batman but we still
can't feel Batman not the old old Batman
the uh most familiar Batman Robert
Pattinson Nirvana deep in his feelings
Batman uh we're gonna get the Batman
part two part two Roman numerals very
classy very classy this has the release
date October 3rd 2025 so a couple years
away
Pattinson's returning obviously Reeves
is returning to direct it probably work
on the story story details are still
very much Under Wraps we'd heard rumors
that maybe a Mr Freeze in this movie
yeah Giancarlo tried to say he was going
to play Dr freeze I would like that I
would make him a doctor I don't care uh
we of course the Riddler's still alive
in jail there's the tease of the Joker
we saw that deleted scene we could still
have Barry kilgan come back as like the
Joker in this the city's been flooded
they're gonna have to deal with that
aftermath all that good stuff saffron
said quote 2025 is going to be a very
big year for DC Superman and Batman
within the same year though they're in
different universes but that's okay uh
so that's very exciting we knew this was
still happening yes they didn't really
mention the Penguin series at all no but
we know that's still going on as far as
it must have been starting to film
either any day now or already is called
Farrell possibly getting an Oscar soon
maybe I don't know I think they're also
we already know a lot about what the
penguin is doing so I think they're just
like you guys didn't know know about you
assumed we were doing a second yeah we
said there's going to be a release
date's huge news that's great that's
great to see but it's hard not to start
making inferences like I got so scared
when there was no Peacemaker yeah but
you know there's still more to come and
they can still add
um and change things as they keep going
now Booster Gold was also announced uh
this is very exciting for a lot of fans
it's gonna be a live action series uh
Booster Gold is he's a fan favorite okay
he's quote a loser from the future who
uses his basic future technology to come
back today to our time and pretend to be
a superhero I love it a lot of fun
I love that idea of like I'll just go to
the past with everyone in the future
this technology is like magic well I'll
go to the past and I'll be a hero so
this was a project that's kind of been
going on for a while like there was they
were trying to put this together back in
2016 but that got scrapped uh Booster
Gold has shown up on occasion and other
series like Legends of tomorrow and
Smallville uh but this is going to be a
Booster Gold Centric show
um they hinted that they're already
talking to an actor to play booster gun
kind of hinted at like we're talking to
someone and it seems very close we're
talking it's going well right and we may
hear about this series and that that
hiring very soon because you know we're
not seeing a movie until 2025 but we're
expecting maybe like uh uh Creature
Commandos maybe has already been in the
works and they're they've worked on
animation or like a TV show they could
get it out sooner so we might see this
in 2024 which would be very exciting uh
this is like a different type of hero
story they're saying focusing on
imposter syndrome like this guy knows
he's not a hero uh and I'm sure the
other current Heroes of our time are
like get out of here future dude you
shouldn't be mucking things up like this
so this will be very exciting to see uh
and we can't wait to see where that goes
I'm excited about Booster Gold I think
it'll be like yeah that should be fun
all of these I have not seen one story
that I'm like oh I'm not interested yeah
I'm excited I want to see all these
things uh we have lots more to talk
about
um but you may have noticed that our our
dear old new rockstars merch talk com
has gotten a little bit of a facelift
our friends at epic hero shop are now
nerd Riot they got a new name folks and
in closer partnership with them our
merch is getting a level up head on over
to new rockstarsmerch.com that link
still works uh to get to see some of the
merch you already know and love like
this two uh we have like a Tales From
The Multiverse shirt featuring Superman
with The Infinity Gauntlet
or you can get this awesome anti-hero
hero Club shirt inspired by The Suicide
Squad I'm wearing the the uh uh yeah
hoodie version of it it's got this you
know this come towards me that's very
Harley Quinn
uh so we got DC stuff on our site
um but you can also still get uh the
um all the merch you know and love with
our logo on it you can get some DC merch
maybe some secret numerals what does
that come say does he know about the
merch does he know does he know about
the merch uh we're also working closer
with nerd Riot to design shirts we think
you would love like our new Quantum
media line that Mt helped design a
little bit the the Vitruvian man with
Kang there you go uh you can get this
stuff it's on the site now you can get
it in time for the Ant-Man uh Premiere
in a couple of weeks where to opening
night and and I you know the website
is my personal favorite what's the
website nerd riot.shop you can go to new
right.shop or you can go to new
rockstarsmerch.com sure you could do
whatever you want there's always a link
in the description of the video yeah
don't worry about typing it in or just
venmo me and I'll get you a [__] Tommy
I'll send you I'm not gonna tell you
what kind of shirt site unseen you could
get a shirt from time it's like a little
bit of a shirt gamble it's a mystery box
shirt for me but it is a great way to
support the channel check out new
rockstarsmarts.com nerd riot.shop
whatever link you want to use sorry I'm
just wearing just the dot shop to me is
the future tells you where you're going
the dot shop is the Dippin Dots of of
browsers I believe ew I don't like
different things prisoner
that's the future oh my God help me oh
my gosh uh okay another project uh that
they announced was Supergirl Supergirl
woman of tomorrow oh
um this is the story of Cara zorrell
we've of course we've had a there was a
super girl movie way in the past in the
80s uh a Supergirl TV show on CBS and
they moved to uh the CW yes we seen
Supergirl before but this is gonna be a
film a new film based on a very recent
comic book run of Supergirl uh Supergirl
is of course usually based in National
City which is very similar to Los
Angeles it's on the west coast of the DC
Universe
um this is going to be based on Tom
King's woman of Tomorrow Comics run that
just very recently ran which is a great
story for Supergirl and Tom King has
been involved in development of this
movie gun said quote we have Superman
who was sent to Earth and raised by
incredibly loving parents and nurtured
whereas Kara was in Krypton she was on a
piece of Krypton that drifted away from
the planet and lived there for the first
14 years of her life among a horrible
situation where she watched everybody
around her die she's a much harsher and
more [__] up Supergirl than we've ever
used thus far and James Gunn said [__]
up which I think was great yeah when you
look at the stories of Superman and
Supergirl you know Superman he's an
alien shirt but he was raised on planet
Earth yeah from birth himself an
Earthling yeah he played Little League
he let his dad die in a tornado who
cares uh but he's an American baby well
his mom was like don't go after him yeah
I've been wanting to get some strings
do not save him Thomas I've got 15 20
years of sexual viability he was ready
to run in and Martha grabbed it and I
was like that's so fast I've been really
interested in the guy who delivers our
milk
the milk pans here uh but but Superman
you know he's raced on Earth he knows
how to be an Earthling he's he's doing
his thing Cara she had a rough thing
she's hers is she's more of a true
immigrant story where she was raised
somewhere else horrible conditions she
comes to earth almost as like a refugee
like looking for Hope and it's like
she's got a lot of trauma to process and
so I think this story will be really
interesting I love that they're they're
bringing in the comic book writer who
had a very successful run and like let's
let's have you you know put your input
on this film uh which I think will be
interesting and it'll be fun to see and
they're describing this as more of a
Sci-Fi story do you think will be a lot
of fun speaking of uh of the comics our
friend koi chandro was pretty uh pretty
uh a few one of his desires was that
James Gunn would identify the comics
that were going to be used as Source
material for these and we did get a
couple but I think what's more
interesting about it is the comic
creators are having input in the
live-action stuff because I it infers in
The Hollywood Reporter article that Jim
Lee is going to be working on the uh
what is the team up one of the the
society or the authority oh yeah uh Jim
Lee was one of the creators of the
authority and it seems like he's working
in the like maybe running the writers
room for it I think it's an interesting
I I think it's to me and I could be
wrong often popular screenwriters become
comic book like they write they do comic
runs yeah I like this shift of like
having the comic book writer being in
the room to break the story screenplay
it's uh which goes with what I was gonna
say it does help especially for
Supergirl because it's like I was always
like why isn't Supergirl mean because
they're like meaner she should have been
like so upset she saw everything right
she saw she wants people saw it she saw
people starve to death on this like
floating chunk of Krypton she was
watching people die and then her mom was
like stop I'm trying to get some let him
float away humans don't want to get some
strings we got a little news about DC
else worlds as well gun and staff
foreign label projects like the Batman
part 2 Joker follow do and Teen Titans
Go to be under the DC elseworlds Banner
they said quote the bar is going to be
very high for projects to be outside of
the DCU the elseworld projects uh but
every now and then there will be
something that lives up to that so
they're still going to do kind of
elseworld stuff we we don't know
anything beyond what's already been
announced so they might wrap it up after
uh you know joke or two or something
like that you know it's when this Teen
Titans Go Run wraps up that might be the
end of that it never will wrap up it may
never happen who knows so we'll see more
about that uh but they did acknowledge
DC elseworld I mean if they don't let
Matt Reeves and Pattinson team up for at
least a Trilogy of Batman movies I'm
sure that'll keep I'll be horrified yeah
I think it will and I think they're
being really kind of effusive about all
this stuff that's the wrong word to use
but uh they're they're being cagey I
think because this Flash movie is is the
the fulcrum on which all of these
Multiverse explanations lie and they
need this Flash movie to come out uh
despite Who's involved with it John uh
Please block trash bag from the chat
although he is correct 100 correct on
that uh but block him trash bag did
point out that yeah
I actually I got I they don't need to be
blocked Tommy baited you when you fell
for it yeah I I just my blackened
fingers itchy uh Tommy tell us about
Swamp Thing you were you were very
psyched about this you mentioned it
earlier a full horror project it's no
secret I grew up in a swamp uh it's just
the way my people are Fiona so many
letters to you
anyway uh once I got everything it was
swamp I was able to look around the way
yeah yeah keep this accent up the whole
time let's go Tommy hey guys I don't
dull yours no no I want to see you do
this I don't the swamp thing's gonna be
a horror film all right what that means
it's gonna have all bits of nasties and
Ghoulies coming at you screams and
scares and jump scares and all of a
sudden cats running across pianists oh
okay let's all right let me explain it
for real now but we had fun it's gonna
be a horror movie and it's it's it's
going to be a straightforward horror
movie not a cutesy little like oh that'd
be scary parts I don't Dr Strange smelly
versus Madness look at music notes dance
Sam Ramey yeah no
this movie gonna make you wet your pants
it's gonna be so scary I guarantee you
Swamp Thing That I mean like the at it's
an origin story for Swamp Thing Swamp
Thing has the potential to be so violent
because he's so angry and confused about
what happened to him why is he Swamp
Thing now why has he merged with the
waters and swamps and and he just loves
this woman that can't possibly love him
back it's so confusing it's so sad and
we're told this will be the origin story
now the last time we saw Swamp Thing
okay it was like a cursed but popular
right I think 11 episode show that was
on DC
the DC Universe was like the app before
they murdered it was on the HBO right
and then this was one of their promo
shows to get you hooked like Doom Patrol
and all that other stuff and everyone
all the the the the screeners people got
the Prescott they were like Swamp Thing
is like the best thing we've seen in a
while the blog reverse went wild and it
was like uh they were filming it in
South Carolina yeah or North Carolina
why the Carolinas they were taking
advantage edge of a big tax break and
then the the government there was like
we're getting rid of that tax break and
they they canceled the show because
they're signed in a weed whacker you
can't afford this show yeah they they
sent in the gardener and he pruned Swamp
Thing down to nothing but they tried out
too just the sweetest most scary
intimidating man alive Derek Mears who
was the swamp he was the Practical Swamp
Thing performer yeah on that show so
there is a Swamp Thing fandom out there
that has been hungry wow and they've
been drinking their gross CMOS drinks
every day they're green swamp juices and
by the way swamp juices is not what you
think it is they don't come in a jar
trust me I know I make my own swamp
juice daily oh Jesus
so yeah we're ready for something and
and uh and James gonna kind of finished
the the video with the Swamp Thing
portion of the video by saying it is a
horror film that will inform the DCU
storyline so it'll still feed into it
yeah but I think the they've set
themselves up for the potential to just
kind of have you know we could all wink
and not about like you know Back to the
Future Doc Brown makes the one line so
that he never has to wear the Aging
makeup again sure so I think I mean like
Swamp Thing could just like someone in
Swanton could be like God why can't
Batman come in and save them they can be
like see it ties in but I have a feeling
there'll be something with the chemicals
or the you know the experimentation that
makes creative so on things that'll tie
into a bigger conspiracy and bigger
Story down the road that's the good the
fun part about DC which I I wish Marvel
could do is that DC didn't put
themselves in a corner of only doing PG
right at different movies so they can
make a horror movie that is genuinely
scary scary not to say that um um my
night by night where we'll find out I
said monster by night werewolf by night
could you imagine if that was rated R
and we already got one it was a little
more I already got one stab but like
versus Swamp Thing well and we know I'm
gonna rip off someone's arm and it seems
like Deadpool three will still be rated
on there it looks like they're getting
they're ready to get there so they gotta
they got it both companies recognize now
there are it is important to have of
some of the content and probably the
majority of the content be viewable by
like kids nine now right like you need
to create new fans look what happens to
Star Wars when you don't create new fans
you end up with 60 year olds that like
wet their pants over like female Jedis
yeah it's like but then it's like my
nephew is it they're not letting it in
Anger yeah they're they're going oh
look at that rate I made wet I think you
can make one that's like for solely for
adults which I think they're kind of
trying to do with like kind of what if
right uh but also it's like again I'm
not trying to be that person my my child
my nephew isn't gonna be the one giving
you guys money I'm the one
that is the recognition that Marvel's
coming along later to the party do the
one thing DC had of them like you said
is like they created content that the
consumers with the wallets would
exclusively be interested in seeing so
and then you know the kids will be like
we gotta secretly watch it like my
nephew will beg me to put it on TV once
my mom goes to bed but I won't do that
James we're not breaking the rules
anymore okay so 2023 we obey the laws
this is our first look at chapter one of
the DCU Gods and Monsters maybe not the
full chapter they said not complete yeah
this is the next two to three years uh
we won't see any of these films until
2025 but we'll we may see some Series in
2024 where of course we're still getting
Shazam for Fury the gods that comes out
March 17th uh we're gonna see Blue
Beetle August 18th Aquaman to December
25th uh and of course the flash is still
coming out what if is Aquaman 2 going to
come out after the chapter one of gods
and must I hope not I hope not get it
out already put it out tomorrow that
would be so confusing um Now The Flash
movie is still coming out gun called it
quote probably one of the greatest
superhero movies ever made and he's made
at least two superhero movies uh which
one uh the flash yeah I've been hearing
they hear good things we know you know
the controversy around Ezra I don't want
to get into that screw that guy or screw
them but like fly ninja 808 you know we
see your Super Chat like yeah they're
still gonna put that movie out there's
other people involved in it that worked
really hard on it and well I think the
reset is the important thing right and I
know that doesn't excuse having a
problematic person you know be front and
center but I do think that they can at
least make peace with the fact that
they're like well we're rebooting a lot
of things and and whatever yeah and I
think that movie is going to be getting
help and going through Rehabilitation
for you know and and having a mental
Intervention which is important and not
and not to be dismissed entirely yeah uh
and let's get to some of your super
chats out there yeah uh morning to
Smokey the Bear salamander get back to
morning Smokey debate uh uh fly ninja
808 also pointing out like he kind of
felt uh that gun maybe dissed the MCU
but honestly Marvel is what started the
shared Universe thing and they didn't
have a plan in the beginning and still
turned out great I don't think there was
any disc going on here I think James
gonna had a great time in Marvel and it
loves to have a little more control I
mean the way he talked about these
characters too it seems like he might
have grown up more of a DC fan first or
like liked DC characters more or maybe
he just wants to see these DC characters
getting I think that's their turn at the
wheel a lot of people that were born uh
before 2001 yeah uh because I think I
grew up yeah
because I started as a DC fan I always
did right yeah I think I did too I think
I was uh definitely a Batman
uh George Andrews asking are they
rebooting The Suicide Squad characters
they didn't really talk about it but
again we kind of mentioned I think the
Waller show is the way in for a lot of
The Suicide Squad characters and who's
really left it's not a lot I mean Harley
Quinn if you consider Chris Elba or
Deadshot Harley Quinn Deathstroke
Deadshot are both still alive yeah king
shark is still alive and I could see
king shark making appearance because he
loves him rat catcher we could see all
them coming back who's the grease that
was Bloodsport Bloodsport yes yes yes I
like how we knew all the other
characters names and we said I liked
that I was like Deathstroke dead shot
blood well they've been acknowledging
that movie that they're the same
character
um trash bag good morning to you as well
Boogie's World thanks for the super chat
um
uh uh sorry Google
Zero garages moo they sent a Super Chat
asking what which do you think will be
PG-13 or lower off the Dome Superman
Legacy uh Superman Legacy for sure
uh Batman Brave and Bold will probably
be PG-13 if you if Superman has it has
to be
a series
I think Waller could be but if it's been
off of Peacemaker there is like a full
scene of a vagina at one point was the
Batman rated R Batman was PG-13 no it's
PG-13 so Batman 2 would probably still
be the authority is not I don't know
about the authority The Authority can't
be it's a movie
I don't know implied violence I don't
know yeah that's that's a tough one
because they're going to merge it in
with the Justice League I I mean as a
film yeah I feel like it's going to be
hard too and I know they said Green
Lantern was like gonna be or the
lanterns uh a TV series like inspired by
True Detective but again they could kind
of throw that lime what what is the
adult version for TV TV okay but they
also have tv-14 yeah so it's like a TV
14 that because it's you know True
Detective for its Gore and it's like
horror it's also like the an exploration
of evil and what does that yeah and I
think there's there's a lot of themes
psychological stuff and stuff and True
Detective yeah I doubt that the Green
Lantern
lanterns is gonna go into that type of
it's created by the guy from Watchmen
though good point uh also salamander
said they were in class but they also
asked what our top three was oh yeah we
should go through our top three that's a
good point Jessica you kind of hinted at
yours oh my number one is Paradise Lost
I am gonna eat up any Greek mythology
okay second one is absolutely lanterns
because a True Detective version to
Inner Space battle I love and third is
absolutely water because I love
peacemakers okay I want as much actually
Authority sounds so good authorities
sounds so good authority authority and
peace and while are my third I can't
choose I want to know more I'm gonna get
some Authority books they're probably
gonna be so expensive I'm gonna go get
something the price is just shot up I
know on Amazon right I'm gonna go on
Amazon as soon as this goes off and try
and get some Authority trade paperbacks
that they have uh I am excited Brave and
Bold obviously you know I'm a Batman man
interesting I want to be excited about
Superman Legacy I just I don't know
James Gunn writing it gives me hope
right uh the the fact that they're
focusing on the kindness element of the
character rather than the like ultra
power basically nuclear bomb in a human
being uh you know uh body uh element I'm
glad we're not exploring that I think
for me I'm gonna go Brave and Bold
Paradise Lost if it is truly Game of
Thrones uh level and then I'm gonna say
why wild card that Booster Gold has
potential
Booster Gold has a lot of attention yeah
very good my I I'm with you there Tommy
my number threes are it's a tie between
Booster Gold and the authority meaning
because I don't know as much about those
yeah excited to see them play out yeah
uh this Authority movie sounds like it
could be a really interesting number two
I'm gonna go with the Supergirl story
okay yeah I mean what if it's like alien
and it's just like crazy like she's like
out in space just watching over it
sounds intense I would love to see this
done well uh I I think that could be a
lot of fun Supergirl reminds me of what
uh uh uh Adam Warlock will be in
Guardians right it's just gonna be
destructive in it and then be like okay
I'm still my my number one I'm gonna put
an asterisk on it because I my number
one really is Batman too yeah because
the Batman really
I had the best time in the theaters
watching the Batman that was a real
surprise so there's a character you
really bonded with uh there was this
police Lieutenant yeah who really wanted
to get that freaking
freak out you better watch your back
pain it's even better before you better
be back it's like drinking before noon
to here you better he better be the main
character in the Batman too uh but I
guess from this new DCU news uh my my
number one uh from all this new DCU
stuff
I'm gonna go I'm I'm gonna go Superman
Legacy okay I want to see this done
right I want to see a Superman story
that really Wows me you know a lot of
people were down on uh Superman Returns
the band Brandon Routh Jordan that was
kind of trying to be like a sequel to
the original job yeah he was definitely
doing uh yeah yeah there's a a man who
plays Lex Luthor that we will not name
who it was a lot of past Pastiche in
that movie trying to like celebrate the
old 70s stuff that didn't work I want to
see a good modern take on Superman I'm
excited to see it let's go let's go DCU
you know uh Rising tide it lifts all
ship that's right and uh the WWE as a
wrestling fan they're the best when they
have good competition aew turned around
WWE to make that analogy here and made
it better you know Corey jandro preaches
this a lot on the show when he's on
Marvel needs competition and DC needs
competition and I think both of them
operating at the height of their
intelligence and at the height of their
abilities this is gonna be really great
for all superhero films for all films in
general let's build it up let's go this
is an exciting time for me to announce
my comic book oh Tommy's got it
craps craps Comics craps Comics yes
we're releasing 15 new books Oh Boy
featuring original characters like no no
no no no no no no no no no no no and ew
what's that smell that's right go to
your local comic book store and say I
gotta take a crack yeah say give me all
your craps and put them right in my hand
uh no bag uh but very exciting stuff I
mean what a day you did it James you got
it in in the month of January uh we've
been waiting all month to hear it and
here it is Eric Voss is going to have
his reaction to all this news up on the
channel very shortly uh and I'm sure
we'll be covering this news all week in
Greater depth and combing through James
Gunn's Twitter that's right reply his
replies to people where he may give more
information yeah we will probably get
some casting news soon again it sounds
like they have like a Booster Gold maybe
ready to go soon so we'll see uh we'll
we'll stay in touch but uh fresh week
welcome back to the break room guys we
were happy to be up early be sure to
like And subscribe if you haven't
already uh we'll be back all the rest of
the week at our normal time uh 305 sharp
unless something changes are we back
today uh I don't know are we back today
or this Today's Show today no this is
today's show we're not back later today
Jessica that's an off question you got
more work to do off camera edit that out
of the show uh but we'll be back
tomorrow at our normal time and all the
rest of the week thank you for tuning in
early for us Breakers we gotta eat some
breakfast already yeah uh oh my God is
rumbling your trash bags out there
have a great day
baby